This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Over the past few days, Californians have watched as the car wildfire has raged through the northern part of the state. The fire started a little more than a week ago. Fueled by dry brush, high temperatures, and strong shifting winds, the fire has moved from a national recreation area into the nearby city of Redding. As of this recording, six people have died, 19 people are reported missing,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。在过去几天里，加州居民一直在注视着卡尔大火（Carr Fire）肆虐该州北部。这场大火始于一个多星期前。在干燥的灌木丛、高温和强烈的多变风向的助推下，大火已经从一个国家休闲区蔓延到了附近的雷丁市（Redding）。截至本期节目录制时，已有六人死亡，19人失踪，
and thousands have evacuated. The fire is only 20% contained. Wildland fires aren't new in California, but with climate change, our fire seasons are becoming longer, and fires are becoming bigger and harder to fight. So for the next two weeks, we're going to look at the issue of wildfire. are becoming longer, and fires are becoming bigger and harder to fight. So for the next two weeks, we're going to look at the issue of wildfire, some design solutions,
数千人疏散。大火的受控比例仅为 20%。野火在加州并不罕见，但随着气候变化，我们的火灾季节变得越来越长，火灾规模也越来越大，更难以扑救。因此，在接下来的两周里，我们将探讨野火问题，
and just how complicated they can be to implement. The Santa Ana Wins of Southern California are sometimes called the Devil Wins. They pick up in the late summer and early fall, sweeping down from the mountains and across the coast. They're hot, dry, and known for creating dangerous fire conditions. In late November of 1980, as the Santa Ana's blew in at up to 90 miles an hour, an unknown arsonist lit a fire near Panorama point in the San Bernardino Mountains. That's reporter Stephanie Joyce.
以及将其付诸实践会有多复杂。南加州的圣安娜风（Santa Ana Winds）有时被称为“魔鬼风”。它们在夏末秋初刮起，从山区呼啸而下，横扫海岸。它们又热又干，以制造危险的火灾条件而闻名。1980 年 11 月下旬，当圣安娜风以高达每小时 90 英里（约 145 公里）的速度吹拂时，一名不知名的纵火犯在圣贝纳迪诺山（San Bernardino Mountains）的全景点（Panorama Point）附近点燃了一场大火。这是记者斯蒂芬妮·乔伊斯（Stephanie Joyce）。
Pushed by the wind, the fire grew and quickly spread down the mountain towards the city of San Bernardino. This is the city's then fire chief talking to a reporter. Again, we had extremely strong winds. Our humidity was somewhere about 10. Another local fire chief said they called in all available resources. And still, it wasn't enough. There was no stopping the fire. All the conditions were just right.
在风力的推动下，火势迅速扩大，并沿着山坡向圣贝纳迪诺市蔓延。这是该市当时的消防局长在接受记者采访。当时我们再次遇到了极强的风。我们的湿度大约在 10 左右。另一位当地消防局长说，他们调动了所有可用的资源。即便如此，还是不够。根本无法阻止火势。所有的条件都刚刚好，
And for what we commonly refer to as a firestorm. In just a few hours, the panorama fire destroyed hundreds of homes and killed four people. It was one of the worst wildfire disasters in California history at the time. It was also the fire that would make a young researcher question our entire approach to wildfires and conclude that we might be able to design our way out of the devastation they cause. Jack Cohen was a few years out of graduate school and a recent transplant to California at the time of the fire. He was working as a research scientist for the forest
形成了我们通常所说的火风暴（firestorm）。在短短几个小时内，全景大火（Panorama Fire）摧毁了数百栋房屋，并夺去了四个人的生命。这是加州历史上最严重的野火灾难之一。这也是一场让年轻的研究人员质疑我们对野火的整个应对方式，并得出结论认为我们或许能够通过设计摆脱它们所带来的破坏的火灾。火灾发生时，杰克·科恩（Jack Cohen）刚从研究生院毕业几年，最近刚搬到加州。他在森林服务局担任研究火灾行为的研究科学家。
service studying fire behavior. He was interested in how the panorama fire had destroyed so many homes, especially when there was such an overwhelming firefighting response. A strike team of engines is five engines, and they had 20 strike teams coming in right away. There would be a whole block of houses on fire and they could not deliver enough water
他很感兴趣全景大火是如何摧毁如此多的房屋的，特别是当时有如此压倒性的消防响应。一个发动机突击队是五辆发动机，他们马上派来了 20 个突击队。有一整街的房子都在着火，他们无法提供足够的水，
so they were calling in more hoses and moving a block down or two blocks down and losing that and then moving further and losing that. So Jack started listening to the emergency dispatch tapes from the day of the fire. Jack is a matter of fact kind of guy, a scientist, rational, not emotional. But almost 40 years later, he still chokes up when he talks about the desperation he heard in the firefighters' voices. The tapes are pretty hard to understand, but you can hear the emotion. Because of how they couldn't fight it. For those of us who mostly see wildfires on TV or in pictures in the paper, it's easy
所以他们不断调集更多的水喉，然后往后挪一条街或两三条街，结果那里的房子也失守了，接着再往后挪，又失守了。于是，杰克开始聆听火灾当天的紧急调度录音。杰克是一个务实的人，一位科学家，理智而不带感情色彩。但将近 40 年后，每当谈到他在消防员声音中听到的绝望时，他仍然会哽咽。这些录音很难听懂，但你能听到其中的情绪。因为他们根本无法扑灭这场大火。对于我们这些大多数时候只能在电视或报纸图片上看到野火的人来说，很容易
to imagine that a wildfire is like a tsunami of flames, spreading across the landscape, and destroying everything in its path. But Jagnew, it wasn't that simple. When he set out to piece together, how the disaster had unfolded. And so one of the things that I did was to look at when the first call came in to dispatch for a fire in this community.
想象野火就像一场火焰海啸，在广袤的土地上蔓延，摧毁所到之处的一切。但杰克知道，事情并非那么简单。当他着手拼凑这场灾难是如何展开的时。因此，我所做的事情之一就是查看调度中心接到该社区火灾的第一通求救电话是在什么时候。
Where was that call from? And where was the wildfire at that time? Okay, help you. Okay, my own posting on how to... I mean, this is true about North Korea. Okay, ma'am, I want you to just get out of there. Just get out. Oh, okay.
那个电话是从哪里打来的？当时野火在哪里？好的，帮您。好的，我关于如何……我的意思是，朝鲜情况确实如此。好的，女士，我希望你马上离开那里。马上离开。哦，好的。
And as Jack was listening to the tapes, he started to notice a pattern. Looks burning. Looks, looks. Two, rough fires. It looks like three rough fires. Yes, sir. I say it looks like 40, 50. People were calling in about houses on fire
当杰克听着录音时，他开始注意到一种模式。房屋在烧。房屋，房屋。两处大火。看起来像是三处大火。是的，长官。我说看起来有 40、50 处。人们打来电话报告房屋着火，
long before the fire front ever reached their neighborhoods. The wildfire was still actually on the other side of the ridge, about a half a mile away, burning up the hill. These houses weren't burning because a wall of fire was racing through the community. They were burning because of something else, the embers. As wildfires burn, they generate embers that are lofted downwind ahead of the main body of the fire.
远在火锋到达他们的街区之前。事实上，野火当时还在山脊的另一侧，大约半英里外，正顺着山坡向上燃烧。这些房屋着火并不是因为有一堵火墙在社区里飞奔。它们着火是因为别的东西——飞火（embers）。当野火燃烧时，它们会产生飞火，这些飞火被吹到顺风处，位于火灾主体的前方。
And Jack realized most of the houses that burned had one extremely problematic feature in common. As it turns out, every house had a flammable wood roof. The embers were accumulating in the crevices around the dry wood shingles and setting fire to the houses from above. Across the street, in a development with outwood roofs, most of the houses from above. Across the street in a development without wood roofs, most of the houses had survived. And while that might not seem like a huge epiphany
杰克意识到，被烧毁的房屋大多都有一个极其成问题共同特征。事实证明，每栋房子都有一个易燃的木屋顶。飞火积聚在干木瓦周围的缝隙中，从上方点燃了房屋。而在街对面，在一个没有木屋顶的开发区，大多数房屋都幸存了下来。虽然这可能看起来算不上什么惊人的顿悟，
that houses with wood roofs burned and houses without wood roofs didn't, for Jack, it was that detail that made him rethink the entire wildfire problem. Because when you listen to other people talk about the fire, they weren't focusing on the wood roofs. They were talking about fire fighting. They were saying nothing could have been done. Like this captain in the San Bernardino Fire Department. If we would have had as many as 500 units spread along the whole hillside there to protect
即有木屋顶的房子烧毁了，而没有木屋顶的房子没有，但对杰克来说，正是这个细节让他重新思考了整个野火问题。因为当你听别人谈论火灾时，他们并没有关注木屋顶。他们在谈论消防工作。他们说当时已经无能为力了。就像圣贝纳迪诺消防局的这位队长所说的那样。如果我们当时在整个山坡上部署多达 500 个单位来保护
those homes, I don't believe that we could have stopped that fire any better than we did under the conditions that we had. The only thing that I feel is that what could have saved those homes would have only been an act of God. Jack didn't think that was right. The problem wasn't the firefighting response. The problem was that the houses were built to burn. And when Jack shifted his focus from the fire to the design of the homes, suddenly he found himself wondering if we were framing the whole problem of wildfire in the wrong way. He wasn't the first to have that thought, but he was the first to do extensive research into exactly how homes burn and wildfires. Some of that work put him at odds with some of the main firefighting agencies in the US and nearly a hundred years of fire policy and tradition.
这些房屋，我不认为我们在当时的条件下能比当时做得更好。我唯一的感觉是，能够拯救这些房屋的唯有上帝的旨意。杰克认为这不对。问题不在于消防响应。问题在于房屋的设计就是为了燃烧。当杰克将注意力从火灾本身转移到房屋设计上时，他突然发现自己在想：我们是不是把整个野火问题都搞错了方向？他并不是第一个有这种想法的人，但他却是第一个对房屋如何在野火中燃烧进行广泛研究的人。他的部分工作使他与美国一些主要的消防机构以及近百年的消防政策和传统产生分歧。
And even though his ideas are simple and compelling, they still haven't caught on in the way that he hoped they would. Maybe because fighting fires is as much a social and political problem as it is a technical one. Do you feel frustrated most of the time? Yeah, most of the time. For most of this country's history, our approach to wildfire has been driven by the sentiment,
尽管他的想法简单且引人注目，但它们仍未像他所希望的那样流行起来。也许是因为扑救山火既是一个社会和政治问题，也是一个技术问题。你大部分时间都感到沮丧吗？是的，大部分时间。在该国历史的大部分时间里，我们对野火的方法一直由这种情绪驱动，
fire is bad. Before colonization, many Native American tribes set fires intentionally to regenerate wild plants and to create grasslands and habitat for game. When Europeans arrived, they brought fear of fire with them. And over time, in much of the country, not only did we do away with the practice of setting fires, we actually started to extinguish naturally occurring fires too. In 1911, that became an official responsibility of the newly created Forest Service.
火是坏事。在殖民之前，许多美洲原住民部落刻意放火来让野生植物再生，并为猎物创造草原和栖息地。当欧洲人到达时，他们把对火的恐惧带了过来。随着时间的推移，在该国的大部分地区，我们不仅废除了放火的习俗，实际上还开始扑灭自然发生的火灾。1911年，这成为新成立的森林服务局的一项官方职责。
And in 1935, that policy even got a name, the 10AM rule. It said the Forest Service should put out every new fire on public land by 10AM the following day. President Roosevelt's civilian conservation corps was on the front lines of implementing that policy. We fought those fires, night and day sometimes. Lots of days, especially in the spring, you could see smokes cleared to the end of the world. The belief was that with enough water and manpower, firefighters could put out any wildfire. In a huge industry rose up around that idea. It grew to employ tens of thousands of people, with hundreds of millions of dollars a year
而在1935年，这项政策甚至有了一个名字——“上午10点规则”。它规定森林服务局应该在第二天上午10点之前扑灭公共土地上的每一处新火灾。罗斯福总统的平民保育团（Civilian Conservation Corps）处于执行该政策的最前线。我们日夜扑灭那些大火。很多日子里，特别是在春天，你能看到烟雾一直蔓延到世界的尽头。当时的信念是，只要有足够的水和人力，消防员就能扑灭任何野火。围绕这个想法兴起了一个庞大的产业。
being spent on planes and helicopters and fire crews. And for a while, that brute force approach seemed to work. But those early firefighters had an advantage. For millennia, before the rise of modern fire suppression, wildfires had burned regularly through America's forests. They would eat up all the fuel. So when there were fires, they were often low intensity and stayed on the forest floor.
它发展到雇用了数万人，每年花费数亿美元用于飞机、直升机和消防队员。有一段时间，这种蛮力方法似乎管用。但那些早期的消防员有一个优势。在现代灭火兴起之前的几千年里，野火一直在美洲的森林中定期燃烧。它们会消耗掉所有的燃料。因此，当发生火灾时，它们的强度通常较低，并停留在林地上。
As firefighters began aggressively fighting fires, that balance started to change, with fewer fires burning, forests started getting more and more dense. That meant when the forest did catch on fire, there was more material to burn and the fires burned hotter and bigger. Effectively by suppressing natural fires, we created something that turned out to be much, much worse. Here's Mark Finney. He's a fire scientist with the Forest Service.
随着消防员开始积极灭火，这种平衡开始改变，随着燃烧的火灾减少，森林开始变得越来越密集。这意味着当森林确实着火时，有更多的材料可供燃烧，并且火灾燃烧得更热、更大。实际上，通过压制自然火灾，我们创造了一些最终变得更糟的东西。这是马克·芬尼（Mark Finney）。他是森林服务局的一名火灾科学家。
Fighting fire really has some unintended consequences that maybe even worse than the fire itself and often are. Since the very beginnings of our fire suppression policies there have been people arguing that it wasn't a good idea to put out every fire, but it took until the 1980s for that idea to really take hold. By then it was also becoming increasingly clear that we couldn't put out every fire, especially as they got bigger and bigger. We're not actually stopping them. We're just delaying them. You know, there's the saying, a fire put out is a fire put off. But even as the public in the 1980s started to accept the idea that fire was natural and necessary
灭火确实产生了一些意想不到的后果，甚至可能比火灾本身还要糟糕，而且往往如此。自从我们的灭火政策开始实施以来，一直有人争论说扑灭每一场火灾并不是一个好主意，但直到 20 世纪 80 年代，这个想法才真正站稳脚跟。到那时，也越来越清楚的是，我们无法扑灭每一场火灾，特别是当火灾变得越来越大的时候。我们其实并没有阻止它们。我们只是在延缓它们。你知道，有这样一句俗语：扑灭一场火，就是推迟一场火。但即使在 20 世纪 80 年代，公众开始接受火灾是自然且必要的，
and fighting it had unintended consequences. Not fighting it didn't seem like a viable option outside of remote wilderness areas. Because how could you stop fighting fires when they threatened people's homes? Which brings us back to Jack Cohen in the panorama fire. Once he started to focus on the home as the problem, not the wildfire, he wanted to know what made some houses more susceptible than others. This was a question that I had in my mind, a curiosity question. What I'm trying to do is to establish a relationship between wildfire and home destruction. I want to know what that linkage is. How does this happen?
而扑灭火灾会带来意想不到的后果这一观点时。在偏远荒野地区之外，不灭火似乎并不是一个可行的选择。因为当火灾威胁到人们的家园时，你怎么能停止灭火呢？这就把我们带回了杰克·科恩和全景大火。一旦他开始把房屋而不是野火当作问题所在，他就想知道是什么让一些房屋比其他房屋更容易受到侵害。这是我脑海中的一个问题，一个好奇心驱使的问题。我试图做的是建立野火与房屋损毁之间的关系。我想知道这种联系是什么。这是怎么发生的？
In the panoramifier, it had clearly been the wood roofs, but in other fires, there were plenty of homes without wood roofs that burned too. So Jack said about learning all of a house's potential weaknesses, all the ways it might plausibly catch on fire. The first thing he wanted to know was how close the flames of a wildfire had to be to a house for it to ignite simply from the radiant heat. To answer that question, he did a series of experiments, including one in the late 1990s in Northern Canada where he sat an actual forest on fire.
在全景大火中，显然是木屋顶惹的祸，但在其他火灾中，也有大量没有木屋顶的房屋被烧毁。因此，杰克开始了解房屋的所有潜在弱点，了解它可能合理起火的所有方式。他想知道的第一件事是，野火的火焰必须距离房屋多近，才能仅凭辐射热使其点燃。为了回答这个问题，他做了一系列实验，其中包括 20 世纪 90 年代末在加拿大北部进行的一项实验，他点燃了一片真正的森林。
So you actually like cut plots into a forest? The boreal forest. And then set them on fire. Yes. And watched them burn. Yes. What Jack found in the experiment was that an entire forest could be on fire, 30 feet away
所以你实际上在森林里砍出了样地？北方针叶林。然后把它们点燃。是的。看着它们燃烧。是的。杰克在实验中发现，整片森林都在燃烧，距离房屋 30 英尺远，
from the house, and nothing. It was fine. But of course, Jack knew that the flames and the radiant heat weren't the only threats to the house. There were also the embers. He frequently found himself standing next to houses, reduced to ash, and next to them, green trees.
却安然无恙。一切都很好。但当然，杰克知道火焰和辐射热并不是对房屋的唯一威胁。还有飞火。他经常发现自己站在烧成灰烬的房屋旁，而旁边就是绿树。
It was a tell-tale sign that the firefront never even reached the home, but the embers did. Jack has a slide show he likes to share with photos of burned houses. And it's like the optical illusion with the vase and the faces. At first you look at the aftermath of a wildfire and all you see is the destruction. And you can see this. But after a few slides, you can almost feel a transition in your eyesight. Suddenly the green trees shift into focus and it's easy to see that the home is often the only thing that's burned. When you see it, it's like a miracle.
这是一个明显的迹象，表明火锋甚至从未到达过房屋，但飞火到了。杰克有一份他喜欢分享的幻灯片，里面有被烧毁房屋的照片。这就像花瓶和人脸的那个光学错觉。起初，你看着野火过后的废墟，你看到的只有破坏。你可以看到这个。但看了几张幻灯片后，你几乎可以感觉到视力的转变。突然间，绿树映入眼帘，很容易看出房屋往往是唯一被烧毁的东西。当你看到它时，就像一个奇迹。
You're like, oh wow. So one of the things that I always try to point out because everybody that looks at news footage and pictures can readily observe no trees on fire and the structure burning. So he did experiments to see exactly how the embers were setting houses on fire. Need discovered, embers like to collect in lots of places, like in the corners of wood decks
你会想：哦，哇。所以我要指出的一件事是，因为每个人看新闻画面和图片都可以轻易观察到没有树木着火，而建筑物在燃烧。因此，他做了实验来观察飞火是如何点燃房屋的。他发现，飞火喜欢聚集在许多地方，比如木质露台的角落里，
and in gutters full of pine needles and in addicts with open vents. Since a lot of people evacuate during a wildfire, there's no one around to douse the embers. They smolder and set fire to the entire house. The more Jack thought about it, the more he came to believe that most ember fires could be stopped with some simple design solutions. I mean, you don't have to live in a bunker. You don't have to cut all your trees down. Jack began to develop guidelines for designing and landscaping homes to withstand wildfire.
以及满是松针的排水沟里和带有开放式通风口的阁楼里。由于很多人在野火期间疏散，周围没有人来扑灭飞火。它们会阴燃并点燃整栋房子。杰克越想越觉得，大多数飞火引起的火灾都可以通过一些简单的设计解决方案来阻止。我的意思是，你不需要住在掩体里。你不需要砍掉你所有的树。杰克开始制定用于抵御野火的房屋设计和景观美化指南。
He started by drawing a buffer based on a conservative interpretation of those Canadian fire experiments. He called it the home ignition zone. The home ignition zone is limited to the house and its immediate surroundings out to about a hundred feet. Between a hundred feet and thirty feet from the house, the goal is to space trees so the fire can't jump between them and is forced to the ground. Between thirty feet and five feet, the goal is to landscape and design so the ground fire loses steam, but removing fuels like tall grasses and wood piles. And within five feet of the house, the goal is to stop the fire dead in its tracks,
他首先根据对那些加拿大森林火灾实验的保守解释画出了一个缓冲区。他称之为房屋着火区（home ignition zone）。房屋着火区仅限于房屋及其向外约 100 英尺（约 30 米）的紧邻区域。在距离房屋 100 英尺到 30 英尺（约 9 米）之间，目标是拉开树木间距，使火势无法在树木之间跳跃，并被迫落到地面。在距离房屋 30 英尺到 5 英尺（约 1.5 米）之间，目标是通过景观设计使地面火势失去势头，但要清除高草和木堆等燃料。而在距离房屋 5 英尺以内，目标是通过铺设碎石地面和浇灌充足的草坪等措施，将火势当场扼杀。
with things like rock beds and well irrigated grass. What I found is that you don't have to be very exotic about your design and materials in order to make your, the houses very resistant to ignition. Jack also came up with a long list of suggestions for preventing ember fires on the house itself, from the big and obvious ones like replacing your flammable wood roof to the smaller, less obvious, like making sure your garage door has a tight seal with the concrete and removing decorative juniper trees, which are extremely flammable. Some of these ideas were pretty intuitive and have been floating around for a long time. In many fire prone communities, homeowners had long been encouraged to clear flammable
我发现，为了让房屋非常耐燃，你的设计和材料并不需要十分奇特。杰克还提出了一长串建议，用于防止房屋本身的飞火，从大而显眼的建议（如更换易燃木屋顶）到小而不太显眼的建议（如确保车库门与混凝土紧密密封，以及移除极易燃的观赏杜鹃花）。其中一些想法非常直观，并且已经在流传很长时间了。在许多易发生火灾的社区，长期以来一直鼓励房主清理他们房产上的易燃植被，并以减少着火几率的方式维护他们的房屋。但杰克的实验使他能够将人们的直觉转化为确凿的数字。
vegetation from their properties and to maintain their homes in ways that would reduce their chances of catching fire. But Jack's experiments allowed him to put hard numbers to people's intuitions. To develop specific evidence-backed recommendations for the changes homeowners should make. And Jack's experiments also showed that when those changes were made, a house was much less likely to burn. In fact, he showed that was the main factor in whether a house was going to burn. It wasn't about the intensity of the fire or its size. In fact, he showed that was the main factor in whether a house was going to burn. It wasn't about the intensity of the fire or its size.
从而为房主应该做出的改变制定出具体的、有证据支持的建议。杰克的实验还表明，当做出这些改变时，房屋被烧毁的可能性要小得多。事实上，他表明这是决定房屋是否会被烧毁的主要因素。这与火灾的强度或大小无关。事实上，他表明这是决定房屋是否会被烧毁的主要因素。这与火灾的强度或大小无关。
It was really about what was happening within 100 feet of your home. And that led him to a further, far more radical conclusion. You can have extreme wildfire behavior, not control that, and yet still have houses survive. In other words, we may not even need to fight fires, as long as buildings near fire-prone areas are designed to withstand them. It wasn't that there weren't other reasons to fight fires, but Jack said there was no need to fight a fire if the only goal was to save houses. That ruled out fighting a lot of forest fires. So we have the opportunity to separate the wildfire
这实际上取决于你家 100 英尺范围内发生的事情。这引导他得出了一个更进一步、更为激进的结论。你可以拥有极端的野火行为，无法控制它，但仍然可以让房屋幸存下来。换句话说，只要火灾易发区附近的建筑物能够抵御火灾，我们甚至可能不需要去灭火。这并不是说没有其他理由去灭火，但杰克说，如果唯一的目的是拯救房屋，就没有必要去灭火。这就排除了扑灭大量森林火灾的可能性。因此，我们有机会将野火
issues from the home destruction issues. We can separate those. Which meant we could let more forest fires burn naturally and finally break out of the vicious cycle of fire suppression that leads to the largest infernos. Jack thought that he had come up with a way to save houses and let fires burn naturally. He thought it was a win-win. So in 1999, he presented a paper about his findings at a fire conference in San Diego. So I give this paper in front of a group of mostly agency people. People with the force service and state fire agencies, people in a position to change policy.
问题与房屋损毁问题分离开来。我们可以将它们分离开来。这意味着我们可以让更多的森林火灾自然燃烧，并最终打破导致最大火灾的灭火恶性循环。杰克认为他想出了一种既能拯救房屋又能让火灾自然燃烧的方法。他认为这是一举两得的事。因此，在 1999 年，他在圣迭戈的一次消防会议上发表了一篇关于他的发现的论文。因此，我在一个主要由机构人员组成的群体面前宣读了这篇论文。森林服务局和州消防机构的人，有能力改变政策的人。
And Jack says they are totally uninterested, like no questions. Jack is up there saying that it's really only what happens within a hundred feet of a home that determines whether it burns and no one seems to care. Except this one guy from an environmental group. And as I'm walking out, he says, do you have a copy of that paper? And Jack's like, sure, here's a copy. A few days later, a newspaper reporter calls, asking about Jack's talk. Jack gives him an interview and the article comes out in the local paper.
杰克说他们完全不感兴趣，就像没有提问一样。杰克站在那里说，真正决定房屋是否会被烧毁的，实际上只有房屋周围 100 英尺范围内发生的事情，而似乎没有人关心。除了一个环保组织的人。当我走出去时，他说，你有一份那篇论文的复印件吗？杰克说，当然，这里有一份。几天后，一名报社记者打电话询问杰克的演讲情况。杰克接受了他的采访，文章发表在当地报纸上。
And I don't exactly remember the headline, but it was something like, Forest Service has its head up its ass. That wasn't the actual title of the article, but the story did imply that basically everything about how the Forest Service dealt with wildfires was wrong. Because remember, the 10 a.m. rule had left us with this huge firefighting infrastructure. The forest service was spending hundreds of millions of dollars on planes and fire crews
我记不清确切的标题了，但大概是“森林服务局脑子进水了”之类的内容。那不是文章的实际标题，但这个故事确实暗示，森林服务局处理野火的方式基本上完全是错误的。因为请记住，上午 10 点规则给我们留下了庞大的消防基础设施。森林服务局在飞机和消防队员身上花费了数亿美元，
and was approving massive logging projects on the grounds that thinning out the forest would help produce the intensity of wildfires and save homes. And Jack was saying, actually, it would be way more effective if you just encouraged homeowners to maintain and retrofit their properties. Nine o'clock in the morning I get a phone call from Region 6 for a service, the Fire Director of Region 6. What do you think you're doing? Jack knew immediately that he was in trouble. The way he remembers the conversation, the director told Jack he was putting those big logging projects in jeopardy. And that put the
并批准了大规模的采伐项目，理由是间伐森林将有助于降低野火的强度并拯救家园。而杰克则表示，实际上，如果你只是鼓励房主维护和改造他们的房产，会更有效率。早上九点，我接到森林服务局第六区消防局长的电话。你以为你在干什么？杰克立刻知道自己惹上麻烦了。据他回忆，局长告诉杰克，他危及了那些大型采伐项目。这把
director in a sticky political situation. But in the middle of getting chewed out by the director, Jack just doubled down. He says he knew what the data said, he knew the science wasn't wrong. And he told the director the logging projects weren't going to do much to save homes. And I said, well, you might have a problem because the research I've done doesn't indicate that that's going to be very effective. That was the end of the phone call and pretty much the beginning of adversity for the next three or four years at least. I don't know, it wasn't at a level two. No, why there was resistance. This is Shauna Lagarsa.
局长置于了一个棘手的政治境地。但在遭到局长痛斥的过程中，杰克反而更加坚持己见。他说他知道数据说明了什么，他知道科学没有错。他告诉局长，这些采伐项目对拯救房屋起不到多大作用。我说，好吧，你可能会遇到麻烦，因为我做过研究表明这不会很有效。那是电话的结束，至少是接下来的三四年里逆境的开始。我不知道，它不在二级。不，为什么会有阻力。这是肖娜·拉加萨（Shauna Lagarsa）。
She's currently the National Director of Fire and Aviation Management for the Forest Service. Back when Jack was first promoting his ideas, she was an in-management. And so, she wouldn't comment on the pushback that Jack says he faced. She does say that over her 30-year career in the Forest Service, she's seen more and more emphasis placed on strategies like defensible space, which means clearing your property of flammable materials.
她目前是森林服务局消防和航空管理全国总监。早在杰克首次推广他的想法时，她就在管理层工作。因此，她不会对杰克所说的他所面临的阻力发表评论。她确实表示，在她效力森林服务局 30 年的职业生涯中，她看到越来越多的重音放在了诸如防卫空间（defensible space）之类的策略上，这意味着清理你房产上的易燃材料。
And she's happy about that. I believe that people take him on ownership in their home and have a defensible space is number one. But there's only so much the Forest Service can do to encourage people to make changes. A lot of that work falls on local governments and individual homeowners. And even today, not everyone is convinced
对此她很高兴。我相信人们对他们的家园承担所有权并拥有防卫空间是第一位的。但森林服务局在鼓励人们做出改变方面能做的事情是有限的。很多工作都落在地方政府和个别房主身上。甚至在今天，也不是每个人都确信
that it's important to invest in the kinds of preparations that Jack recommends. Yeah, you know, so it's kind of scattered across a country. Some communities don't believe a fire will ever happen where they're at. It'll never happen to me. And I'll never have to evacuate. And so I'm going to keep my trees and shrubs right by my house. And unfortunately, time is telling us or showing us that it does happen. Fire has no boundaries and no preference for for where it burns. And in the meantime, the Forest Service has a
投资杰克推荐的那种准备工作是重要的。是的，你知道，所以它有点散布在全国各地。一些社区不相信他们所在的地方会发生火灾。这永远不会发生在我身上。我永远不需要疏散。所以我打算把我的树木和灌木留在我的房子旁边。不幸的是，时间正在告诉我们或向我们表明它确实会发生。火灾没有界限，也没有偏爱它在哪里燃烧。与此同时，森林服务局拥有
congressional mandated duty to fight fires. Last year, the federal government spent more than $2 billion fighting fires, and just a small fraction of that on prevention and mitigation efforts. Our culture reviews fire as primarily an emergency response activity. But if you treat fire only as an emergency response under emergency circumstances, you're missing out on all the preventative care you could do. This is Mark Finney again. You remember, he also works for the Forest Service. And while he was
国会授权的灭火职责。去年，联邦政府花费了超过 20 亿美元用于灭火，而其中只有很小一部分用于预防和减灾工作。我们的文化将火灾主要视为应急响应活动。但如果你只在紧急情况下把火灾当作应急响应来对待，你就会错失本可以做的所有预防性护理。这是马克·芬尼。你还记得，他也为森林服务局工作。虽然他
on board with Jack's ideas, he also understood that there were huge challenges to implementing them. There were reasons why they didn't catch on at first. We can't just throw a bunch of scientific papers on the table and have everybody read them and go, oh, jeez, thanks. You know, that's what I needed. Now we have a different view of how things work. Sure. There's too much history behind the idea that we've got to do something about fire, whether
赞同杰克的想法，但也明白实施这些想法面临着巨大的挑战。这也是它们起初没有流行起来的原因。我们不能只是把一堆科学论文扔在桌子上，让每个人都读一遍，然后说：“哦，天哪，谢谢。”你知道，那正是我需要的。现在我们对事情的运作方式有了不同的看法。当然。在“我们必须对火灾采取行动，无论它是否有效”这种观念背后，有着太多的历史。我们公众期待看到飞机飞过熊熊烈火、向其投水的高潮迭起的大片。但当社区将杰克阐明的原则付诸实践时，它们确实管用。
it's effective or not, we, the public, expect to see dramatic shots of airplanes flying over raging fires, dropping water on them. But when communities put the principles Jack articulated into practice, they work. There are several communities in Southern California built with wildfires in mind that have survived when nearby homes didn't. But those homes are mostly custom designs, engage communities. They have homeowners associations that enforce strict rules about vegetation clearing and home design. Making changes elsewhere is more complicated.
南加州有几个社区在建造时就考虑到了野火，当附近的房屋未能幸存时，它们却幸存了下来。但这些房屋大多是定制设计，社区参与度高。它们有业主协会，负责执行关于植被清理和房屋设计的严格规定。在其他地方做出改变则更为复杂。
For starters, many homeowners may not even have a hundred feet of space to clear and fire proof. It's expensive to replace your roof. For renters, they may not have the authority to make changes to their homes. And in many cases, there aren't incentives for people to invest. Plus, many homeowners just kind of instinctively get that the odds of being in a wildfire are extremely low. There are more than 40 million homes in wildfire prone areas, and only a few thousand burn every year. Without someone compelling them to do it, homeowners might decide it's just not worth spending time and money to change their properties.
对于初学者来说，许多房主甚至可能没有 100 英尺的空间来进行清理和防火。更换屋顶价格昂贵。对于租房者来说，他们可能没有权力对他们的房屋进行更改。在许多情况下，人们缺乏投资的激励措施。此外，许多房主凭直觉认为身处野火中的几率极低。火灾易发区有 40 多万栋房屋，而每年只有几千栋被烧毁。如果没有人强迫他们去做，房主可能会觉得花时间和金钱改变他们的房产根本不值得。
So even though Jack's ideas are pretty simple, they're not simple to actually implement in the real world. Jack tells this story about a friend of his who said that modifying homes to make them fire resistant isn't rocket science. And I said to him, no, this is much harder. This is social science. And his comment is, oh jeez, we're screwed. Jack's ideas have become more mainstream over time.
因此，尽管杰克的想法非常简单，但在现实世界中实际执行起来并不简单。杰克讲过这样一个故事：他的一个朋友说，改造房屋以使其耐火并不是火箭科学。我对他说：“不，这要难得多。这是社会科学。”他的评论是：“哦，天哪，我们完蛋了。”随着时间的推移，杰克的想法变得更加主流。
Fire agencies like the Forest Service now talk a lot about defensible space. There's more emphasis placed on homeowner responsibility. Jack also helps start the prominent organization Firewise, which promotes fire preparedness. Shana Lagarsa, the Forest Service Fire Director, says that the enormously destructive fires of the last few years have also forced people to think about how to make their homes and properties more fire resistant. And I think every year there's going to be more awareness about wild and firefighting and evacuations and do you have defensible space or not just because of the trends every year you know we thought last year was the largest and most devastating fire year and now we have this year which is larger and more devastating than
像森林服务局这样的消防机构现在经常谈论防卫空间。人们更加强调房主的责任。杰克还帮助创办了著名的组织“防火智慧”（Firewise），该组织旨在促进防火准备。森林服务局消防总监肖娜·拉加萨表示，过去几年极具破坏性的火灾也迫使人们思考如何让他们的房屋和房产更具耐火性。我认为每年都会有更多关于野火扑救、疏散以及你是否有防卫空间的意识，仅仅因为每年的趋势，你知道，我们认为去年是最大、最具破坏性的一年，而今年则比去年更大、更具破坏性。
last year human fatalities, firefighter fatalities. And with climate change the fire season is only getting longer. So when I asked Lagarsa if she could imagine a future like the one Jack proposes where the Forest Service would get out of the firefighting business. Boy, so I think we're a long ways from that, you know? So, I mean, we're all bored for a fire-adapted communities and resilient landscapes and for, you know, folks that have a defensible space around their structures and more healthy resilient national force systems land.
人员伤亡，消防员伤亡。随着气候变化，火灾季节只会越来越长。因此，当我问拉加萨她是否能想象未来杰克所提出的那种森林服务局退出灭火业务的景象时。天哪，所以我想我们离那还很远，你知道吗？所以，我的意思是，我们都渴望适应火灾的社区和具有弹性的景观，并且，你知道，人们在他们的建筑物周围有防卫空间，以及更健康、更有弹性的国家森林系统土地。
We're a long ways from that. We are a long ways from that. The Forest Service is currently fighting several dozen fires across the Western United States. When you're that busy running around putting out fires, literally, it's hard to focus on how to prevent them from being so destructive in the first place.
我们离那还很远。我们离那还很远。森林服务局目前正在美国西部扑救数十起火灾。当你忙于四处奔波灭火时，从字面意义上讲，很难专注于如何从一开始就防止它们造成如此大的破坏。
Jack retired from the Forest Service a few years ago, feeling like all his research hasn't made much of a difference in the end. When he's watching the news, especially coverage of the past few destructive fire seasons in California. He's noticed there isn't a lot of talk about making homes more fire resistant, or clearing defensible space. Instead, there's a lot about firefighting. The fire swept down the valley with apocalyptic fury. Over night, the battle against the giant infernos intensified. Overwhelmed firefighters did what they could.
杰克几年前从森林服务局退休，觉得他所有的研究最终并没有产生多大影响。当他看新闻时，尤其是对加州过去几个破坏性火灾季节的报道。他注意到没有多少关于让房屋更具耐火性或清理防卫空间的讨论。相反，有很多关于灭火的讨论。大火以末日般的狂怒席卷了山谷。一夜之间，与巨型大火的战斗加剧了。不堪重负的消防员尽其所能。
We're not wind blowing, there's not much you can do. There's no way you could stop a fire front like that. The fire is now scorched more than one of the very frustrating things that I had experienced this past summer, particularly from the California fires, is the continued sense of fatalism. Oh, well, there's nothing that could be done. Well, no, the bottom line is that we can do something, it just doesn't have anything to do with controlling the wildfire. This fire is now 45% contained in mandatory evacuation orders or so. Watching news footage from those California fires, something stands out,
风刮得这么大，你无能为力。你绝对无法阻止那样的火锋。大火现在已经烧毁了……我在过去这个夏天经历的非常令人沮丧的事情之一，特别是在加州大火中，就是宿命论的持续存在。哦，好吧，没有什么可以做的。好吧，不，底线是我们可以做点什么，它只是与控制野火没有任何关系。这场大火现在有 45% 得到了控制，并发布了强制疏散令等等。观看那些加州大火的新闻画面时，有些东西很突出，
especially if you've spent a lot of time with Jack. Once you get over the shock of seeing neighborhoods reduce to ashes, and the drama of firefighters talking about how there was nothing they could do to stop the flames, your eyes shift to something else. The green trees, untouched by fire, surrounding the burnout homes. We are really in a battle with nature that nature is more powerful than we are. About 11,000 firefighters are battling the fire's putting in ruling shit. Next week we'll be continuing to explore the issue of wildfire and just how hard Jack Cohen's ideas
特别是如果你花了很多时间与杰克在一起的话。一旦你克服了看到社区化为灰烬的震惊，以及消防员谈论没有什么可以阻止火焰的戏剧性，你的目光就会转移到别的东西上。绿树，没有被火触及，环绕着被烧毁的房屋。我们确实在一场与自然的战斗中，自然比我们更强大。大约 11,000 名消防员正在与火灾进行艰苦的搏斗。下周我们将继续探讨野火问题以及杰克·科恩的想法在现实世界中有多难实施。
can be to implement in the real world. We'll look at one community in Southern California, which has been threatened again and again by fire. We have a preview of that story coming up right after this. Next week on the show, we're going to look at just how complicated it can be for a community to figure out what to do when they're faced with the regular threat of destructive wildfires. And to do that, we're going to spend some time with one community in Southern California. It's called Montecito. It's right next to Santa Barbara, and Darryl Kagle has lived there since the mid-60s.
我们将关注南加州的一个社区，它一再受到火灾的威胁。我们将在之后立即预览该故事。下周的节目中，我们将探讨一个社区在面对毁灭性野火的定期威胁时，弄清楚该做什么是多么复杂。为此，我们将花一些时间与南加州的一个社区在一起。它叫蒙特西托（Montecito）。它紧邻圣巴巴拉，达雷尔·卡格尔（Darryl Kagle）自 60 年代中期以来一直住在那里。
It's a lovely place, and it's where I grew up, and it's very comforting to be in the place that is so familiar. The hillsides are covered with chaperale, it's a scrubby brush with yellow flowers, and the neighborhoods are lined with eucalyptus. But Montecito's beautiful landscape is also what makes the community particularly vulnerable to wildfire. The chaperale and eucalyptus both provide excellent fire fuel. The canyons that sit below the hills of Montecito are cozy little spaces where fire can easily
这是一个可爱的地方，也是我长大的地方，在一个如此熟悉的地方会让人感到非常安心。山坡上长满了长柄灌木（chaparral），这是一种开着黄色花朵的矮小灌木，社区两旁种满了桉树。但蒙特西托美丽的风景也使该社区特别容易受到野火的侵袭。长柄灌木和桉树都提供了极佳的火灾燃料。坐落在蒙特西托群山之下的峡谷是舒适的小空间，火灾很容易在那里
take hold. And the town so-called Sun-Downer Winds blow hot dry air from the desert up over the mountains and through the canyons, spreading that fire. For this landscape, fire is predictable and it is inevitable. And coupled with a multi-year drought, it is becoming unmanageable. We had no idea that fires were going to increase in size and frequency like they have. Maybe it's like the frog in the pot slowly coming into a boil. It's just getting worse slowly. For decades, the residents of Manacito exhibited a kind of stubborn pioneer streak that characterizes a lot of Californians. After fires, they'd rebuild and continue on with their lives. But that
扎根。小镇所谓的“日落风”（Sun-Downer Winds）将来自沙漠的炎热干燥空气吹上山脉并穿过峡谷，从而蔓延了火灾。对于这种地貌而言，火灾是可预测的，也是不可避免的。再加上多年干旱，它正变得难以控制。我们不知道火灾会在规模和频率上像现在这样增加。也许就像锅里的青蛙慢慢被煮沸一样。情况只是在慢慢变坏。几十年来，蒙特西托的居民表现出一种顽强的开拓精神，这也是许多加州人的特征。大火过后，他们会重建并继续生活。但这种
kind of optimism is getting harder to sustain as fires become more frequent and more intense. And as the community is forced to reckon with rebuilding again and again and again. We are entering a new time when, because of the weather and the impacts of climate change, and long-term extended drought, that fires have reached a new level of intensity that it's causing us to have to,
随着火灾变得更加频繁和强烈，乐观情绪越来越难以维持。由于社区被迫一次又一次、一次又一次地考虑重建。我们正在进入一个新时代，因为天气、气候变化的影响以及长期的严重干旱，火灾已经达到了一个新的强度水平，导致我们不得不，
in some cases change our tactics or strategies and to start to, you know, reevaluating how we're gonna deal with this, you know. We're on that story next week. 99% invisible was produced this week by Stephanie Joyce and our senior editor Delaney Hall. Mix and Tech production by Sharif Yisif, Music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is our Senior Producer, Kurt Colsteth is the Digital Director. The rest of the team is Avery Trouffleman, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lee,
在某些情况下改变我们的战术或策略，并开始，你知道，重新评估我们将如何应对这一点，你知道吗。我们下周将继续报道这个故事。本周的 99% Invisible 由斯蒂芬妮·乔伊斯（Stephanie Joyce）和我们的高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）制作。混音和技术制作由谢里夫·伊西夫（Sharif Yisif）负责，音乐由肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）创作。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特思（Kurt Colsteth）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括埃弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、维维安·李（Vivian Lee）、
Terran Mazza, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to KUOW and to Tom Collagen for research assistance. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. You can find them all at radiotopia.fm.
泰兰·马扎（Terran Mazza）以及我——罗曼·马斯。特别感谢 KUOW 以及汤姆·科拉根（Tom Collagen）提供的研究协助。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的无线电街（Radio Row）。99% Invisible 是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由所有播客中最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立集体。你可以在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. Run Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But I invite YouTube, Bask, and everything 99% invisible at 99PI.org. Radio Topia. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与有关该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我（Roman Mars）并在 @99PI org 上@该节目。也有 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit。但我邀请你访问 YouTube、Bask 以及 99pi.org 上的所有 99% Invisible 内容。Radiotopia。来自 PRX 的 Radio Tapio。本期节目尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。